-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"My Dumb Tradition" stories
from you guys.
This first one's from
@HillCompany. He says...
-Aww.
-It was a beautiful thing.
Christmas treadmill.
We're not using it
for anything else.
-Yeah, yeah.
Either that or clothes.
-Exactly.
That's when I knew
we were in trouble,
when my dad bought a treadmill
when we were growing up.
This is when you could
actually buy a treadmill
and have one in your house
from, like,
Montgomery Ward or something.
You could -- I don't even know
if Montgomery Ward exists.
But you could buy a treadmill.
And he had the treadmill,
and put it in --
I think it's in our living room.
We didn't have
any other place to put it.
And he was on the treadmill,
and in the water holder
he had a beer.
-There you go.
-That's it right there.
-America, baby. America.
-Going for it.
He's just enjoying himself.
Going for a stroll.
Just going for a stroll.
-Walking.
-Watching "Barney Miller"
or whatever the heck he watched.
This next one --
-Watching "Barney Miller."
-You know, kid shows,
like "Barney Miller."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-This one's from
@KristenRose124. She says...
[ Laughter ]
-Ohh! That's cold!
-"The Oscar goes to you clearly.
You had a 10-minute
conversation."
[ Laughs ]
Oh, fantastic.
Oh, man.
This one's from
@jiggypants76.
-76? Oh, okay.
-Yeah.
I'm hoping it's 'cause
he was born in '76,
not because there was
75 other jiggy pants.
[ Laughter ]
Anyways -- jiggypants.
That's not a thing, right?
-Jiggy pants?
-No.
-I don't know. You can get jiggy
with your pants, right?
-Like wearing your pants? You
don't get jiggy with your pants.
[ Laughter ]
Jiggypants. He says...
[ Applause ]
-Glug, glug.
-This one's from
@abbyelizabethh. She says...
Look at this. Aww.
[ Applause ]
-Come on! That's cute!
-That's a cute baby.
That's a cute baby.
This one is from @palevell.
He says...
-What?!
[ Applause ]
-What?
Yuletide logs.
[ Audience groans ]
-"What's wrong, honey?"
"I flushed last night!"
"All right. You didn't -- Santa
will -- He's still coming."
-[ Laughs ]
-This one's from @RevDMQ.
He says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's all for Santa.
-This last one's from
@jroddcassell. He said...
Aww. That's sweet.
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.